The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: So as he
gives an introduction,
myself along with Catherine,
David, [INAUDIBLE],,
and Charlotte
[? are going to present ?]
you guys Probablistic and
Infinite Horizon Planning.
To give you a brief overview of
what we're going to talk about,
we're going to start with the
Quadrotor motivating example.
We're going to move into
planning with Markov decision
processses, give you a little
bit about value iteration
before discussing
heuristic guided solvers.
And we're going to go into the
more stochastic case, partially
observable Markov
decision processes
and operating in belief space.
So we very often now see
quadrotor motion planning
as a problem, given, for
example, with the Amazon
fulfillment center.
We start with a goal
configuration, start
configuration, set of
actions we can take,
and some type of reward
function or cost function.
So for instance, if we
have a quadrotor starting
at the Amazon
fulfillment center,
and we want to get
to 77 Mass Ave,
and let's say we want to take
the shortest path to get there.
We would follow the
red dashed line.
But, as we can see, it comes
very close to these obstacles.
So we're looking
at very higher risk
for mission failure, crashes.
If there's any
uncertainty in its path,
we're going to have a problem.
So one of the ways that we
can compensate for that is we
can also done a
green path, which
is adjusted to give us
a little bit of space.
Are there any more questions?
So as you can see, the
level of uncertainty
allows us to determine how
easy or difficult the problem's
going to be to solve.
On the easier side we have
deterministic dynamics
and deterministic sensors.
In this case our
actions are going
to be executed as
commanded, and our sensors
are going to tell us
exactly where we are.
This will be something like
dead reckoning validated
through sensing, very redundant.
If we moved to a little bit
more at a difficult case,
we have deterministic dynamics.
Our commands are
still being executed,
but maybe we have
a noisy camera.
So we have some
uncertainty in the sensors.
These are the cases where
we would see dead reckoning,
but we would compensate
with Kalman filtering
to get rid of that noise level.
Now, down at the--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
is dead reckoning?
PROFESSOR 1: It's essentially--
you are saying I want
to execute this option,
and it's going to
execute it exactly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR 1: Then
towards the bottom,
we have stochastic dynamics
and deterministic sensors.
So in this case maybe
there's some uncertainty
in our actions.
But we can validate
through sensing.
This is where we're going
to spend the next section
on Markov decision processes.
And then briefly,
later in the lecture,
we're going to talk about this
most difficult case, which
is the stochastic dynamics
and stochastic sensors.
Our execution maybe, maybe
not, our sensors maybe a little
bit of noise.
And this is where we
see partially observable
Markov decision processes.
PROFESSOR 2: Can we make
just a brief clarification
of the dead reckoning?
So dead reckoning is
where you estimate
you position using a
probabilistic file,
but you don't use any
observation stuffs.
That's the thing.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
So we talked a little bit
about action uncertainty,
where we're going to focus.
And this is a case
where, for instance,
even if you tell a quadrotor
to stay in its place
and a gust of wind
comes by, it's not
going to stay in that
same place, right?
It's going to have a
little bit of movement.
And we can see, this
causes things in disparity
where you have a
command of trajectory
and your actual trajectory and
then you need to associate.
So in order to
compensate for that,
we want to model things
with that uncertainty
or else we have these
higher situations where
we command to follow some line.
We don't incorporate
the uncertainty,
and we see a crash.
So this allows us to introduce
Planning with Markov Decision
Processes.
So MDPs have a set of states--
some actions you can
take-- a transition model.
So essentially,
what's the probability
of reaching some state
if you take an action?
An immediate reward function
and a discount factor.
This discount
factor is important
because it allows
us to prioritize
gaining an immediate
reward as opposed
to an uncertain future award.
So the concept of, bird in the
hand is worth two in the bush.
Now we want to find
an optimum policy
that will essentially
back an action--
the best action--
for each state.
And what we hope
to get from this
is maximized expected
lifetime reward.
So we want to maximize the
accumulative reward we get over
the times.
So let's walk
through an example.
If we have a quadrotor with
a perfect sensor, and let's
put it in this environment
[INAUDIBLE] 7x7 bridge.
Our set of states are obviously
[INAUDIBLE] space in them.
Can anybody tell me what
some of the actions might be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: (LAUGHING) Yep.
Up, down, left, right.
In this case, we call them
North, South, East, West,
or Null.
The next thing we need
for this example--
arbitrarily gave ourselves
a transition probability.
So we said that you have
2% chance of following
your commanded action with
a 25% chance of moving
to the left or the right.
Next we have the
reward function.
And again, we
arbitrarily decided
that we want it to be a reward.
If you get to the state 6-5,
the increment [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Alicia, you had
[INAUDIBLE] left or the right,
is that clockwise or
counter clockwise?
Let's say you had planned
to go to the right,
would that mean you have a 75%
[INAUDIBLE] or 25% chance of
[INAUDIBLE]?
What if you just
waited [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR 1: We said
clockwise, counterclockwise
from the intended
direction of action.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PROFESSOR 1: Uh-huh.
And finally, we give ourselves
a discount factor of 0.9.
So let's assume for
a second that we
have our optimal policy.
And let's say that our optimal
policy says, from this state,
we want to take
the action North.
Right?
As we discussed, we
have a 50% chance
of going North and 25% chance
of going to the left or right.
So after that time step,
these are possible states
that we could end up in.
Right?
So now let's assume
for a second that we
can take our next action.
And our next action
says, go North.
Again, we have the same
probability distribution.
And these are the
states we could end up
in after two time steps.
We can see that this starts
getting very complicated,
right?
And there are increasing
amounts of uncertainty.
So does anybody have any
ideas on how we could
collapse this distribution?
Keeping in mind that our
senses, at this point,
are deterministic.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Fly to a corner?
PROFESSOR 1: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR 1: We could do that.
AUDIENCE: You just sense
how far away the red box is.
PROFESSOR 1: We could do that.
AUDIENCE: Quick comments.
So the blue state
is not actually one.
PROFESSOR 1: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: So the problem
is you're not actually one.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The issue is if
you went to (1,3)
and then you transitioned
to the left, that's where
the 0.0625 is coming from.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] then,
shouldn't those numbers always
are actually 1--
your probability distribution
always are actually 1?
PROFESSOR 1: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So it's just a point.
It's just off the screen.
PROFESSOR 1: We would add
another section to the screen
and just move the grid over.
We just cut it off for graphics.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
So those are all great points.
The easiest way to do it is
just take an observation.
So at this point we say,
after our first time set,
we weren't sure which of
these three states we were in.
So we took an
observation and said,
wait, we're actually here
with complete certainty.
So to make this a
little bit clear,
we're going to look at
it from a tree view.
Right?
We said that we
started at a state.
We took an action.
And this is our possible states
we could have ended up in.
We're going to collapse this
by taking this observation.
And now have a
complete study here.
And we take our
next action and see
that we have moved out here.
So this allows us to basically
ignore the history of states.
We have the same percentage
probability from each time set.
This will be really useful
in completely collapsing
the distribution every single
time you take an observation.
Anybody have any
questions on that?
OK.
So let's go back now and
figure out how he came up
with his optimal policy.
They way we do that is
through dynamic programming.
There's two different ways.
You can do it either through
value iteration or policy
iteration.
For this lecture, we're going
to focus on value iteration.
So let's take this
same example we had.
We still want to maximize
the expected reward.
And so to start, we're
going to initialize
the values of each state to 0.
Let's for example,
start at (2,0).
We're going to
focus on suite 6-5.
And we're going
to say that we're
going to take the Null
action to start with.
From there you can
see with a probability
distribution 4, 6, 5, we
have a 50% of staying.
We have 25% chance
of going to 5-5.
And a 25% chance
of going to 7-5.
The next item of
information is the values
at each of those states
that we could end up in.
And currently,
they're all set to 0.
And finally, the
most important part
here will be with the
reward [INAUDIBLE]
6-5, taking the null action,
regardless of what state
you end up, is going to be 1,
as we defined in our initial set
up.
So let's see how we would
calculate the next time step
value of the state.
You'd start by taking
probabilities, right?
And from there, we would
add the reward here.
And because we said
that the reward does
not dependent on the state
we end up in, [INAUDIBLE]
should be across all
three probabilities.
From there, we're going to
add in the discounted value
that we had from before.
So a way to look at this
in a more generalized form
is to say that across all the
states that you can end up in,
you're going to look at the
probability of ending up
in that state.
You're going to
multiply that by the sum
of the reward and the discounted
lifetime value that it has.
So we want to make sure
that we're getting the best
possible values.
So we need to incorporate
all the other actions that we
can take from that state.
So what's going
to happen is we're
going to take that
general formula,
we're going to repeat it over
all of the possible actions.
And then we're going to
take the maximum of that.
So, for this example,
the state is very easy.
All of them are the
same for this case.
But we go fast, and we
say we get a value of 1.
And we update it by
showing the graph.
This gives us what's called
the value [INAUDIBLE] Backup--
or Update equation.
This will be really
important because it
reaches across the
entire states space
and allows us to
provide a history.
So what this would
end up looking
like is we're going to
iteratively calculate
the values across the
entire state space So at t0,
we determine that
all the values are 0.
At t1, (6,5) gets a
value of 1, and at t2, we
see that value start
to propagate out.
Make sense so far?
So the way this works is you
would repeat those iterations
until your changes in value
become what we would consider
small enough, which would
indicate your approximation
is close enough
to the real value.
From there, you would
extract the optimal policy
from the lifetime values.
So you see the [INAUDIBLE]
in the Bellman equation.
And you're now just
taking the action from it.
And you would map those
actions to your states.
An example of what this might
look like propagating out--
if you say blue was the
reward and red is an obstacle,
et cetera--
you can see, as that
value propagates out,
you start seeing your
policy by the arrows.
Anybody have any questions?
So one last thing to
mention about this, though,
is the complexity
for each iteration
is dependent on the size
of the state space squared
and the number of
actions you can take.
So you can imagine, as your
state space expands or you
gather more actions
it's very complex,
in which case time and
value depiction becomes
very time intensive and costly.
So this allows us to move into
the Heuristic-Guided solvers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] transition,
one quick question.
Can I just get a show of
hands-- how many of you
have learned value iteration
before versus how many of you
have seen it for the first time?
So how many have seen it before?
OK.
And then, how many is
this their first time?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Any questions
on value iteration
before we jump in?
It's going to be an essential
part of how we're going
to do [INAUDIBLE] solvers.
Anyone who hasn't [INAUDIBLE].
So the most important thing
we said about value iteration
is that it's super slow.
It's going to have to go
over every possible state
and every possible
action that it can take.
Our state space is
multi-dimensional,
and we can take a lot
of different actions.
That going to be really costly
and really hard to [INAUDIBLE]..
So the approach we're
probably going to want to take
is using some sort of
best first search applet?
Who can tell me some
example algorithms
that already do that?
AUDIENCE: A star.
PROFESSOR 3: A star.
So that's very good.
And that's exactly what we're
going to base our stuff off of.
The A star is for
deterministic graph search.
If we have a graph, we
can use it heuristic,
and we walk down it
and search the space
that we're most interested in
until [INAUDIBLE] variable.
So going to introduce to new
items focusing on the last one.
AO star is an
algorithm we can use
to search for graphs that
have this "and" problem.
AO stands for And Or graphs as
opposed to the simple graphs
that we have [INAUDIBLE].
The And is a way to express
probabilistic coupling
between edges.
So if we explore one
thing, we might have
to explore other functions.
We'll discuss that a little
bit more in the next slide.
LAO is a bit more
of a generalization.
What it does is allows
us to search loopy graphs
and deal with the
probabilistic coupling.
And allows us to search
and find the best path
with a heuristic guided
algorithm over infinite time
horizon, possibly revisiting
states using the tools
we just had--
valued iterations-- to
understand what the next best
thing to do is.
So we'll talk about exactly how
to get our MDPs that we just
saw, these little arrow
examples to these And/Or graphs.
We'll talk about two cases.
One simple one where we could
apply the AO star algorithm
is where you have a qualicopter.
And if you command
an action North,
you have a high
probability of going North,
but you might go East.
And vise versa.
If you go East,
you might go North.
This is expressed here
with the growing tree.
And these And edgers
that connect it.
But despite the action of
reading my command from 0 to 0.
We might end up
in (1,0) or (0,1).
Right?
As we propagate
outward, you can see
how we're never
going to loop back
to a statement we've been to.
We're going to be moving in the
Northeast direction constantly.
Our [INAUDIBLE] and our
probability distribution
across this tree explands.
And that's the
coupling of the edges.
Because as we explore
down the tree,
we have to explore all
the edges together.
Anyone have any questions
on just this kind
of conversion formulation?
AUDIENCE: I have a
broader question.
We mentioned that MDPs
deal with finite states.
Do we always just
discretize a continuous row
into a set of planning states?
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
That's our prerequisite for
searching over the state space.
We can do that as
finely as possible,
but yes, discretization
is there.
So now let's look at this case.
Instead of the Northeast, let's
say it's not deterministic
whether we command an
action north or South
that we go north or south.
Here we see this loopy
structure begin to emerge.
We see that we might--
on our first action commanding
North, we might go to plus 1.
And then commanding North
again, but we have our
And edge and our
probability distribution
is [? back ?] to 0.
What this does is
this loopy structure.
And this is exactly what
we're going to be exploring.
This is a very
real world scenario
where it's a very likely we
might return to somewhere
we just came from, just because
of the uncertain dynamics
we have.
This is the type of
problem [INAUDIBLE]..
So we're going to use the
LAO to start out with.
We're going to talk about
the three main things
that [INAUDIBLE] has a
heuristic guided envelope.
And what that means is that
we have our large state space
here.
But we're only going to
look at a portion of it.
This greyed-out portion.
We're only going to
look at the portion that
is interesting to us-- the
portion that provides us
with the biggest rewards--
the portion that's reachable
if we follow an optimal policy.
We figure this out with
some admissible heuristic.
We'll estimate our
rewards just like A star.
The idea here was that
we'll keep the problem small
so we don't have to search the
valuation for a giant state
space.
What we'll do next is at
the state space expands,
we get a bigger
picture of the states
that we're interested in.
We're going to do
[? an audio ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
And then we're going to figure
out what the best action is.
And in the ideal
case, the states
that we would never reach
using an optimal policy
are never going to be explored.
Because our policy is going to
say, no don't go over there.
That's a dead end.
Or that's getting you farther
away from [INAUDIBLE]..
So we're going to be searching
in a very specific part
of the state space that
is useful to explore--
that will get us closer and
give us a higher reward.
What's important here,
the L stands for Loops.
It's an extension of
the AO star algorithm,
which is by itself is an
extension of the A star
algorithm.
We can handle infinite
horizon problems,
like transition
in different ways.
And really models the real world
scenarios we're interesed in.
Any questions so far
on the broad scope
of what AO star is going to do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you put the
[INAUDIBLE] what you're doing
over here, but--
PROFESSOR 3: Sure.
The AO stands for And Or graphs.
So that's graphs that we have
here edges that are coupled.
If you took time to
do this transition,
you might end up here or
you might end up there.
So that's the notion
that of this probability
coupling, that we'll see
in action as we [INAUDIBLE]
we're going to do, we're
going to input this MDP or AO
graph with transition
probabilities or reward
function heuristics.
These are all things
that we defined
prior to figuring out a plan.
What we're going
to come out with
is an optimal policy for
every regional state.
It's a little different than
what value iteration is,
which is an optimal policy
from every possible state.
But we argue that
that's all we need.
If we know where we're
starting and we follow
our optimal policy,
we're only going
to explore a certain
portion of the state space.
And we're going to
explore that together.
[INAUDIBLE] plan
a little bit more
efficiently than iterating for
a high [INAUDIBLE] heuristic.
Any questions on that?
So we'll define some
terms that we're
going to use throughout this.
We've already talked
about our state space.
This is just a
small portion of it
that we're going to
work with as we're going
to walk through this example.
Next we're going to define
something called our envelope.
And that's the
sub-portion of our states
that we're going
to be looking at.
We're going to initialize that
to just this zero [INAUDIBLE]..
But as we progress through the
algorithm, it's going to grow.
It's going to grow only in the
areas that we're interested in.
A subset of this envelope
is the terminal states.
Now these aren't
goal states, these
are just [INAUDIBLE]
of our space
that we've added
to our envelopes.
And this is what it would be
in the expanded [INAUDIBLE]..
And it's just the nodes that
haven't been expanded yet.
Here they haven't drawn
anything incredible
but you can imagine the
state space goes out
further because [INAUDIBLE].
You can imagine that
this goes out further.
And they're keeping
track of the nodes
that we haven't expanded yet.
Or likewise, we've showed that
we initialize [INAUDIBLE]..
The other few things that
we're going to define-- we've
already defined the states
that are in our envelope.
That's the blue or the red.
We're going to define cost
heuristic or reward function, R
E, and a transition probability
matrix, or set of matrices,
that we're going to use our
optimal policy search on.
What's important here is
that our reward function
and transition
probabilities are slightly
altered to account for the
fact that we haven't explored
the entire state space.
We see here that if a node
is in ST, in other words,
it's one of those
terminal nodes.
We're going to say we
can't transition out
of it, because we don't know
what's beyond it so far.
And we're going to set it
for reward to be a heuristic.
Whenever we think
that the reward is
going to be when we begin
to explore and go further.
Like I said, we're just going to
feed this into a policy search
just like we discussed
with value iterations
on the sub problem.
And we're going to search for
an optimal policy [INAUDIBLE]..
So far so good?
This is the general steps.
This is very text-y, but
we're going to definitely walk
through every single step.
We're going to do two full
iterations of the algorithm.
So like I said, we're
going to create RE and TE.
That's are reward function
transition probabilities using
the definitions we showed.
We're going to use
value iteration
to find the optimal
policy of the sub space
that we're interested in now.
And then this is probably
the most important step.
Knowing this optimal policy, we
take a look at what new states
that aren't in our
terminal states--
nodes that we haven't
explored yet--
what new states we
might visit now.
So let's say we have our policy,
and it says we'll go North.
And we know that we haven't
explored the North state yet.
We know this is the
state that we're
going to reach following
what we consider now to be
already an optimal [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the states we're
going to expand next.
We're going to do
some bookkeeping,
adding them to the
terminal states [INAUDIBLE]
once we expand it, then
adding them to our envelope.
What's important here
is that we're only
going to add states that we
visited yet to our envelope.
And this is basically
the little hack
that allows us to deal
with loopy graphs.
We're not going to
continually explore nodes
that we might reach a second
time, probabilistically.
We're going to let
value iteration handle
that [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
states are expanded.
I'm the one who got
confused on that.
Are you saying that you're
going to just repeat
until there aren't any
more terminals to look at.
And if that's the case, how
is that possible if you have
an infinite horizon [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Sure.
So if you can imagine-- and
we'll talk about termination
at the end.
But you can imagine that as
we have these terminal states,
but you have a policy
that guides you
to a part of the state space
that we've already expanded.
Imagine you've
reached your goal.
Your optimal policy is
going to say, stay put.
Right?
And it's not going to
say, move North again.
AUDIENCE: It's just
the goal [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Essentially,
the goal state
is definitely an example
in the more extreme case
that there's nothing else
you can do that's going
to get you closer to our goal.
The idea is that your
policy on your sub space
never tells you to
go to a terminal.
Nobody can [INAUDIBLE]
inherently worse than
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Planning
optimal policy
means running value
iteration entirely.
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
We were going to treat it
essentially as a black box.
But the trick here is
that we're doing it
on a smaller portion of
space of a different world.
All right.
I'm going to put
the steps up there.
Hopefully you can see this.
But for now, we'll
just walk through
from the beginning of
what we're going to do.
So we said that our envelope
and our terminal nodes
are just at 0 to start.
So very simply, we
use these definitions
and say, OK, the
transition probability
as 0 to any node right now is 0.
Because it's in that terminal.
[INAUDIBLE] That's just so that
we don't transition out of it.
We can develop the policy
based on only this portion
of the space [INAUDIBLE].
And our reward
function, we're just
going to apply it to be
the heuristic [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's say that's 20.
And for a move-on from there.
[INAUDIBLE] started
to value iteration.
And we'll run this
value iteration.
So this is a very basic case.
We're just going to-- we're
using this to kind of build up
the machinery, understand
what we're doing.
It's a very basic case where you
only node we have is that zero.
We can't transition out of it.
All we have is some heuristic.
So the only thing we
can do is nothing.
So the action we're going
to take from S0 is nothing.
Very simple case just to get
us warmed up and understand
what's happening.
So using this policy and knowing
that those 0s in our terminal
node are node reset.
We're going to take
the intersection
between this terminal mode set.
And the nodes that we might
reach following our policy.
And we know that we're at S0.
And we know that action that
our optimal policy says to take
is not.
So we know we're there.
And we know it's in
our terminal node set.
So that's the only thing
that we could reach so far
using our optimal policy.
So far so good?
Clear?
So that's exactly what
we're going to expand.
Just expand S0, A, B,
and C defined those
to our terminal nodes.
So that's up there the
symbols [INAUDIBLE]
from our terminal nodes
added as children.
Then we added the
children to the end.
Here we go.
We're going to do
a little bit more.
the same thing again.
But now we obviously have more
nodes and a bigger sub space
to explore.
So using these definitions
we see our reward function
is a tuple of the node
that we start from.
And so this S0.
And one of these three actions.
And we'll take A1, A2, and A3.
When we have our instantaneous
reward functions, 6,4, and 8
as being our rewards
from doing those actions.
From A, B, and C, no matter
what action you take,
it's just heuristic.
That's part of it.
And likewise, we're going to
take a look at this transition
probability [INAUDIBLE].
This is for [INAUDIBLE]
transitioning from a state S0
for saying that if we take
actions A1, A2, and A3,
what's the probability of being
done in nodes A, B, and C?
If you look so far
here, we're going
to look at something
deterministic.
If we take an
action, we'll end up
where we say we're
going to end up.
And we'll see how this algorithm
collapses down to A star
if everything's deterministic.
We're also obviously going to
look at the probabilistic case
where we say [INAUDIBLE]
small probability that it
might end up with [INAUDIBLE].
That's going to
necessitate that we're
going to have to look at
and expand B together with A
if we were to decide we
want to try [INAUDIBLE]..
And likewise, if we
try to take action A3,
we have to expand
them all three nodes.
So the tighter the probabilistic
coupling, the more of the space
we're going to have to explore.
So just off this, assuming
that if you take action A1, A2,
and A3, can someone tell me what
the policy is for the rewards
here?
And we're interested in a policy
from S0 what we're going to do.
Take a look at the
rewards and judge
what the best action to take
is from a purely deterministic
sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
do you add [INAUDIBLE]
or do you just [INAUDIBLE]?
You have the reward that
you have gotten so far.
PROFESSOR 3: Does that help
you answer the question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] student.
PROFESSOR 3: So the
policy preference
says, from S0, take action A1.
And that's going to stay there.
[INAUDIBLE] from A to C, there's
no action to take [INAUDIBLE]..
What that means is that the
nodes that we might reach
that are in our terminal
state set, using our policy,
is node A. All right.
So that's the node
going to expand.
And this is where you really
see that all we've done
is collapse down to A star.
A star would say, OK.
What's the best node
using some heuristic.
Action a1 one takes
us to that best node,
and we're going to
expand just that.
So when everything
is deterministic,
basically this algorithm
collapses down to A star.
Nothing super interesting.
The interesting
case does come up
when we start doing
more probablistic ones.
That's where nodes
are probabilistically
helpful to the
scanned graph sense.
So now we have our policy.
The policies are politely
going to remain the same,
because they have very little
probability on the edge actions
that we might
accidentally hit up.
What would I want to look
at is what [INAUDIBLE]
and how reachable following
our optimal policy.
So we talked about that if
we were to actually read.
We know some probability of
ending up in [INAUDIBLE] nodes.
So taking action A3 makes
C, 2, and A all reachable.
What's reachable in
taking action A1?
AUDIENCE: A and B.
PROFESSOR 3:
[INAUDIBLE] And that's
where we get the notion on
this probabilistic algorithm
that we're going
expand things together.
Explore the part
of the state space
that we reach both
higher optimal polity
and that we might accidentally
end up in if we [INAUDIBLE]
the policy.
And this is what guarantees
that we'll have an action
to take from any state
that we intended to go to
or that we might
end up [INAUDIBLE]..
That's how our state
expands, our envelope
expands to encompass only
the reachable and interesting
states that we want to look at.
It's not as simple
as just examining
not only the heuristic,
but with A start
because we have this
probabilistic [INAUDIBLE]..
You can see that if you have
a tighter coupling, then
you don't get to exploit
this optimization as much.
For example, A3 we
would have had to expand
more as opposed to A1.
We can just stick to A and B
and ignore expanding C for now.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Our [INAUDIBLE]
We know that when people
do the statistic [INAUDIBLE].
So in this case, if you take
action a because of a and b,
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: So in
the complete sense
of running this algorithm,
we shouldn't print it.
Because what if we do?
If we have that 2%
chance, [INAUDIBLE]..
We need to have a
policy for correcting.
So we end up at
B. You can imagine
that these are going to try
to push back to whatever path
that A was looking for.
I suppose that the
probability is low enough,
you can have some
cutoff percentage where
you've decoupled [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR 2: So
just a quick point.
So I think that's an excellent
point and an excellent answer.
We're going to talk
about next week--
exactly what's going
to happen and if you
can prove lower
probability on the paper
right here will be
lecturing on that.
Good question.
PROFESSOR 3: That also
gets us into the sense
that if every state in the
world were probabilistically
coupled-- let's say we had some
transporter to go with the Star
Trek examples.
If we had this transported that
non-deterministically put us
in any state in
the world, we have
to explore the whole world,
because we could end up
[INAUDIBLE].
So luckily that's not the case
yet and we can take advantage
of the fact that we ended
up most likely where
we commanded with some
probability of [INAUDIBLE]
This is exactly what
we just talked about.
We coupled these nodes
with this And edge.
And we expand those, too.
Is everyone understanding
the holding intuition,
and the logic for why both
of them have the [INAUDIBLE]??
Even if there's only a small
probability that we end up
[INAUDIBLE]?
So and this is what
we're going to repeat
until the states are expanded.
You can imagine that
the next time we
run our value
iteration, we're now
running it on all of
these colored nodes--
both the blue and the red.
We can imagine
that next time, now
that we have a little
bit more information what
lies beyond A and B, that
our policy might say, oh,
you know what?
Actually from S0 C, action
A3 was the best to take.
What that does is say,
OK, with a regional map,
it's A, B, and C. And
we expanded those nodes.
We'll we've already
expanded A and B,
so we move into the next
part of the sub space,
that as we gain
more information,
we run value iteration
and we can expand on why.
Steve asked a good question.
When we did our dry run,
about whether there is a way
to save on the
computation you did
prior to the value iteration and
add these [INAUDIBLE] states.
And we've looked
at it a little bit.
I've seen some stuff.
But I haven't found a paper
that specifically deals with it.
You can imagine
how you've already
run value iteration on your
previous iteration [INAUDIBLE]
and you add the new terminal
edges which you'd expand on.
And you run them again
until it stabilizes.
And that way you've
saved the computation
of having to run valuation
multiple times [INAUDIBLE]
state space.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
trying to think of how
this is different from
something like [INAUDIBLE]
for [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: I think I don't
know enough about that.
But my basic understanding
says that what's useful
here is it's this
explicit [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know how
much [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: And also, as long as
your heuristic is admissible,
it's guaranteed [INAUDIBLE]
not all [INAUDIBLE] algorithms.
Just like A star is optimal,
as long as you've got
a consistent [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: All right.
So that's definitely
the idea here.
We coupled these in
the only explored
of the portion of
the state space
that we'll reach an
optimal policy [INAUDIBLE]..
So we'll talk about quickly
another determination.
We've touched on most of this.
So it's most likely
when there are
no more states to expand this
when we've reached our goal.
It's when our policy that we
run on our entire envelope
from value iteration
doesn't say that we should
go to anymore
terminal [INAUDIBLE]
that we haven't looked at
yet, that we haven't seen yet.
We've said that those
are only the things that
are reachable and needed.
Both, reachable because we're
following optimal policy,
and needed, only if
we might accidentally
end up in the probabilistic.
This is gives us the sense of
rigorous that we get policy
on the entire state space that
we can end up in following
the optimal policy.
The third bullet
here touches on if we
don't expand the states that
are probabilistically coupled
and we do accidentally
end up there,
we risk getting lost
and not having a policy.
We can compute this all off line
and have a plan before we even
start planning to
know exactly where we
want to go even if our
dynamics aren't [INAUDIBLE]..
We're come back to this.
This was our motivating example.
And so we show that
these real platforms can
be modeled
stochastically and then
we can pretty easily
deal with that.
Search our state space and
deal with those probabilities
and expand the nodes
that we might end up.
Right?
And the heuristic
allows us to not
have to explore these
areas of state space.
I never actually end up there.
We'll always be a
commanding toward 77.
We're never going to
try to command backward.
Sure, if there's a gust of wind
and we have some probability
there.
But you can imagine that
we're going to only explore
a small portion of this.
Because we'll always be
trying to correct to get back
to the top four blocks.
And using our
reward function, we
get to determine if we
want to fly a quick path
or if we want to
fly a safer path.
For example, our time
times our probability
[INAUDIBLE] we want to
perhaps reduce that.
All right.
Are there any questions
about planning with MDPs,
anything like that.
I love this stuff.
So the more questions,
the more I get to talk.
Fine.
What I'm going to be
talking about for the rest
of this lecture is
extending beyond MDPs
to a broader class
of problems called
POMDPs, Partially Observable
Markov Decision Processes.
I love this stuff.
I think it's really cool.
They're really fun problems.
We're going to talk about why
they're so much harder to plan
with, to execute--
but why they're
important to at least know
about so that you can model
real world problems with them.
And then we're going to
delve into a case study
of a specific POMDP solver.
We're not going to go into as
much detail as we did for MDPs,
but we're going to look
at what powerful results
we can get by
planning with POMDPs.
PROFESSOR 4: So first,
I want to rephrase
this in the overall talk.
Right?
We have this spectrum
of uncertainty.
And coupled with
uncertainty is difficulty
of planning, of solving,
of executing a problem.
And we've killed
these first two cases.
That was really easy.
And then we just discussed
the bottom [INAUDIBLE],, MDPs.
What I'm going to
talk about is the case
where both your dynamics and
your sensors are stochastic.
Why is that important?
It's because when
we first saw this
slide-- our motivating
example slide,
we only saw the left hand side.
We said, our actions
are uncertain.
But good news, we have
a perfect sensor--
a perfect camera.
But that's unrealistic.
I think, we have
all, to some extent,
experienced the fact that no
sensor is totally perfect.
Your camera might have
fluctuated pixel values.
Your laser range finder is
going to never read out exactly
the right number all the time.
You can have a camera in
different lighting conditions
that will behave differently.
You might not be able to
observe your full state.
That's, in a way, an
imperfect sensor, right?
If I'm in this room,
I have imperfect eyes.
I can't map out
all of MIT's campus
because I'm blocked by walls.
How can you deal with the
fact that you can't see all
your obstacles all the time?
We've already talked
about some cases--
that there are some
algorithms that can help us
with that, like D Star Lite.
But can you reason about these
things probabilistically?
And then finally, you might
be in a non-unique environment
where you cannot resolve your
state with certainty no matter
how good your sensors are.
Imagine you're in a building
with two identical hallways.
You're dropped off
in one of them.
How can you figure
out where you are?
You can't unless
you start exploring.
And so we've got to deal
with this uncertainty,
right? it's Part of
every single problem.
When observational
uncertainty is slowing,
you can maybe ignore it.
But it's there.
And so we're going to
formulate this as a POMDP,
a partially observable
Markov Decision Process.
And this next slide is
just like the MDP slide.
Hairy, but important.
Right?
We can formulate a POMDP,
which is seven elements.
And MDP too five.
Most of them for all those
are carried over here.
We've got our set of
states where we can be.
We've got a set of
actions what we can do.
We've got our transition
model which says,
given that I
started in one state
and then I took
an action, what's
the probability I end
up somewhere else?
And like David
was talking about,
hopefully that distribution
is pretty local--
we're not teleporting
all over the world.
We've got our reward function.
This is exactly the
same as for MDPs.
And we've got our
discount factor down here.
The key difference of POMDP
is these two elements.
We've got a set of
possible observations
and a probabilistic
model for the probability
of making an observation given
your state and the action you
just took.
Now it's important, I
think, it matches up really
well with real
world sensors having
this probabilistic model.
If you have a laser range
finder, for example,
and you're standing one
foot away from the wall--
now a perfect sensor
would always say,
you're one foot
away from the wall.
You're one foot
Every single
reading is constant.
But realistically, there might
be Gaussian noise, for example.
Or at a more extreme
case, it says,
your one foot away
from the wall.
You're two feet.
You're right there.
There's this distribution.
And so you would ideally
characterize this distribution.
And you plug that
into this model
and that formulates your POMDP.
This sounds really hairy, but if
you work through just a sample
iteration of living in a POMDP
world, that's not too bad.
You start at some state,
S. You take an action,
A. With some
probability, you're going
to end up in a bunch of
different states based
on your transition model.
At that point, we can use the
lessons we learned from MDP
land where we said, when
we make observations,
we reduce our uncertainty. we
collapse into a single state.
So we say, let's
make an observation.
But this time, observations
aren't guaranteed
to resolve all our uncertainty.
So we make an observation.
And that observation
is probabilistic
based on our current state
and the action we just took.
And again, obviously, it
depends on your current state.
Because if you're one
foot away from a wall,
hopefully you'll get a
different characterization
of observations than if you're
20 feet away from the wall.
Otherwise, your sensor
it's totally useless.
Are there any questions
about this formulation?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
Quick question.
So we will take observation,
any other observation and then
you try to infer
which state you're in,
is it just a clustering problem?
For instance, the multi-cluster
Gaussian [INAUDIBLE] models.
So class A, class B,
class C, which are state,
then taking an
observation there's
a high probability
[INAUDIBLE] This
is what we're tyring to do for
each observation over here.
So we're trying to find
clustering [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 4: So you
could, I imagine,
implement an algorithm
where, yeah, every time you
make an observation, you
then try to say, all right.
What's my most likely estimate,
or maybe my [INAUDIBLE]
least cost estimate?
But inherent with
that is the risk
that you're discarding a
lot of information, right?
Because you're going to
generate a probability
distribution over your state.
And so, yes, you
can say, I'm going
to stick with the maximum
likelihood estimate.
But if you can,
you should probably
try to maintain
that distribution
as long as possible.
OK.
And we'll see that
this is really
computationally
expensive unless you
start making some assumptions.
And in the case study
we're going to look into,
that's exactly what [INAUDIBLE].
But I've seen a lot
in the literature
that as much as
you can, you want
to maintain these distributions
for improved accuracy.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well, we're going to compare
now the execution of a POMDP
to the execution of an MDP.
We started out-- we're living
in the same real world.
We've got our same
transition model.
Everything is peachy.
We take action one, and
we want to go North.
We have this distribution
that we generate the states.
And at this point,
what did we say?
We said, we hate
the fact that we
have to deal with three cases.
Three is two too many.
So let's make an observation
to collapse this distribution.
Now I've described a
lot about noisy sensors,
right, where basically
it's a true measurement
plus some noise, maybe
Gaussian distribution.
There's another partially
observable sensor
you can have in the
POMDP which really
feeds into the name,
Partially Observable.
What if you can only
observe part of your state?
For example, if you're
living in an x-y grid,
maybe you can only
observe your y dimension.
This match up, in a
real world example,
to quadrotor flying
down a hallway.
Catherine was working
on a DARPA project
with quadrotors
flying down hallways.
If the hallway is too long,
your laser range finder
isn't going to be
able to determine
where you are along one axis.
But it can tell where
you are along another.
And so that's what I've said.
I've said, pretend this
quadrotor has that sensor.
We can only observe
its y component.
And it says, my
y component is 3.
I have no idea what
my x component is.
Well, this sucks.
Right?
Because we got
rid of this state,
but then we couldn't decide,
are we at state (1,3) or (3,3)?
There's no way of
resolving this.
So we can re-normalize.
We can add in the effect from
the observation probabilities
saying, maybe, in
fact, I'm far more
likely to observe a y
component of 3 if I'm at (1,3).
But in this case, we
say it's equally likely
to make that observation
for those two states.
And so now we've got to
deal with these two cases.
And so we can take
our next action.
Instead of resetting
to a single state,
we've got to keep
growing this tree.
And what's the key
difference between this
and when we were
executing our MDP?
Except we didn't
manage to collapse back
to a single state.
We didn't manage to
reset the problem.
And this is annoying.
Because you can't
execute a policy and say,
I'm certain that this
is my configuration.
So your policy can't
map from exact states
to actions, because you
never know your exact state.
Does this make sense?
Has everyone lost hope
in planning, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in here because--
so from the left to
the right, you're
basically mapping from one
belief state to another belief
state.
So it's like a one arrow thing.
But and then from
that second layer,
you should have two arrows.
One with probably
0.5 that observes 3,
and it gives rise to that
belief state it just showed.
In one, with probability of 0.5
where the sensor is being 4.
Because if you have
a 0 probability
of looking at (2,4),
you might as well just
observe 4 as well as your y.
So in this case, I'm not
sure if you were just
trying to show one branch
of your POMDP planning,
but basically what
you have to do
is you would go like
this to the second layer.
You would have a branch with
a 0.5 probability on either.
One giving you 3,
one giving you 4.
For the one that is showed,
you've got that relief state.
For the other one, you get the
state (2,4) with probably 1.
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah.
So you were perfectly
describing planning, right?
I should have made
this more clear.
This isn't planning.
This is executing.
We have this policy that
we're going to execute.
And so if we were
planning, we would
have to consider all these
branches and say, well, yeah.
There's a 50% chance here I'll
end up here, in which case,
my y value is going
to read 4 and you
have to grow this whole thing.
I'm saying, no.
This is real time execution.
yeah.
Great question.
Any others?
Well, this is a great time
to transition to, well,
we can't just magically
be handed these policies.
How do we actually
generate them?
How do we start planning
in the belief space?
The belief space is
the space distributions
of possible configurations.
So I'm going to talk about a
general class of algorithms.
A lot of planners in POMDP
land and the belief space
plan with probabilistic
roadmaps- PRMs.
The goal is to generate a
policy that maps from a belief
state to an action.
And I'm going to go
into a little more
what a belief state is.
But the general
algorithm in this graphic
illustrates these four steps.
We're going to sample points
from the configuration space,
as if everything
was deterministic.
We're going to connect those
points to nearby points.
And define nearby
however you want.
It could be your closest
neighbors, all neighbors
within a radius, whatever.
As long as those edges don't
collide with obstacles.
Once you've done that, somehow--
and there's some magic in this--
you're going to transform
your configured action space
probabilistic roadmap
to a probabilistic road
map in the belief state.
Great.
Once you've done
that, you can just
do shortest path depending on
whatever cost function you use.
And what's really cool is you
get different paths for when
you stay in the
configuration space
and when you go to
the belief space.
So the green path, that
bottom right figure,
seems a lot longer
than the red path.
And the reason is the green path
was planned in the belief space
and followed a lot of landmarks
that the quadrotor could
take measurements off of.
So it was really confident
about its position
whereas the red path is the
shorter path that had a higher
likelihood of a collision.
And we're going to look
into that figure more later.
I'm going to segment this
algorithm into two parts.
The first part-- these
first two steps--
it's just probabilistic
road maps.
Who here has heard about
probabilistic road maps?
Raise your hand.
OK.
50/50.
I'm so excited for the
50% who haven't heard.
One of the top
algorithms, in my opinion.
It's really simple, and
it's really powerful.
Here's basically almost
a complete implementation
of probabilistic road maps.
It's pseudocode so don't copy
paste, but it's almost there.
You're going to
construct a graph.
You're going to add
your start goal.
Your start configuration
being the green dot and then
goal configuration, the red dot.
And then you're just going
to keep sampling notes
those from the free space.
You say, how about (2,3)?
You're going to add
that to your graph.
You're going to connect that
node to a bunch of other nodes
nearby.
And then you're
just going to keep
sampling until maybe
you have enough nodes
or maybe until you have
your complete path.
Should be happening there.
And then once you've
got this whole graph,
you can just find the
shortest path along that.
And there are some
really cool results
that if you sample in a good
way, and so on, asymptotically.
As you start
sampling more, you're
going to asymptotically approach
the best path in a completely
continuous space.
The power of
probabilistic road maps
and a bunch of
randomized algorithms
though is that they scale
pretty well to high dimensions.
So you don't need to actually
consider the continuous space.
You can just sample [INAUDIBLE].
Are there any questions about
probabilistic road maps?
Really cool.
If you are interested, and
you just heard about PRMs.
You probably haven't
heard about RRTs.
Those are also really cool.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
[INAUDIBLE] question.
So for any node, [INAUDIBLE]
at this uniform example
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 4: Sorry.
When you're choosing
where to place the dot?
Or what to connect to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
there's a dot there
on the side [INAUDIBLE] right?
So when I do the sampling, I
just [INAUDIBLE] this node.
I uniformly choose one
of them [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 4: So in general,
probabilistic roadmaps,
you can throw in whatever
sampler you want.
The way this particular one--
the way I implement this is
you sample points uniformly
from the entire space.
If it's inside an obstacle
and you remove it,
once you place it--
this was connect
to the K closest--
I think K is 7 in this case.
And if there's an edge
that if that edge collides
with an obstacle, remove it.
I'd be happy to go into more
detail for that PRMs later.
All right.
But that's not enough.
Because what we described
as PRMs in the configuration
space, but what we
need to do is somehow
elevate a PRM from the
configuration space
to a belief space.
And this is really hard.
We don't have access to
these raw configurations.
Let's imagine we were in
this really simple world
where the quadrotor could
be in three possible states.
One, two, three.
Really easy, right?
Sample a bunch of points.
They're going to end up
in one, two, or three.
You could pretty quickly
cover the entire space.
But this simple
configuration space
will transform to the belief
space becomes infinite.
You have infinite possible
distributions to consider.
There is the
distribution where you
have 100% chance probability--
100% probability that you're
in state 1, 100% probability
that you're in state 2.
100% probability that
you're in state 3.
And then everything in between.
We went from three to infinite.
This is not boding well.
And even if you start
saying, well, I'm
not going to consider
the whole distribution.
I just care about the
mean and the variance,
it's still not pretty, right?
Well, this is where we have
to start making approximations
And this is where you
start getting differences
in POMDP planners-- where
they make assumptions,
where they make approximations.
So these images are
from the belief road map
paper from the Robust Robotics
group a couple of years ago.
But I'm going to talk about
a different planner soon.
But the idea behind a
lot of these planners
is maybe we can start saying
what these distributions are
going to look like
based on our models.
So to our planning problem,
if we know we started at (2,3)
and we know our
transition distribution,
we can start saying, well, this
is my probability distribution.
And then when I make
and observation,
I can build
distributions off that.
And so, if you
could exhaustively
propagate these distributions
forward, that would be great.
But it's unrealistic.
And I just want to point
in terms of the visual way
to represent these
distributions.
A really nice way of saying,
in the deterministic world,
you have these dots and edges.
In the probabilistic
world, these circles,
these ellipsoids,
represent uncertainty.
Typically, it's the one
standard deviation or three
standard deviations away.
And so you can start
building into the map,
these are the distributions
and the variances
I can see in these nodes.
Are there any questions
about this stuff.
All right.
Well, we're going to delve now
into a specific case study.
Feedback Based Information
State Roadmaps--
FIRM.
From now on, that's the only
way I'm going to refer to it.
The idea behind
this is you're going
to sample mean configurations
from your configuration space.
Then you want to
build an LQR-- that's
Linear Quadratic
Regulator controller--
around these mean points.
And that will generate what
variance you can tolerate.
So LQR controllers, if you
don't know, they're really nice.
Around a small region
around a point,
they can drive a quadrotor,
for example, to that figure.
And so if you build these LQR
controllers around points,
you can say, all
right, anytime I end up
in this cloud in
the belief space--
so any sort of distribution and
can bring it back to that mean.
And so now, what we've done is
we've generated every point,
we just need to connect them.
And the idea is if you
have a feedback based,
they can get from one cloud to
another anywhere in the clouds.
Then you can get
from point to point.
All right.
This is how you
generate the graph.
And what's cool is the
way they formulated
the problem is they
said, well, set up
the cost of executing an edge.
We switched from
rewards to costs
because we're pessimists now.
Well, the cost is going
to be a linear combination
of the expected time to execute
that edge and the uncertainty
along that edge.
Now, this is actually
really cool to play with.
What do you think would happen
if I set beta to 0 in this?
Like, what sort of
[INAUDIBLE] would you get?
I will cold call because
I know a few names here.
Anybody?
I don't want to cold call
someone who may [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: You're going
to get the shortest path.
PROFESSOR 4: Shortest
path, that's right, right?
This turn goes away.
The cost is a
function of the time--
shortest path.
Now, what's cool is one
day I was messing around
with this code.
I'm like, I wonder what happens
if I set alpha to 0, right?
So your cost is purely a
function of uncertainty.
In turns out what the
quadrotor does it just
hangs out where it starts.
It says, I'm in no hurry.
I know where I am.
I'm just going to stay here.
But I find this amazing, right?
Because this almost
models behavior even.
You could start
saying, do I want
to be a risky quadrotor
or a safe one?
Like, how important it is for
me to get somewhere on time
or be safe?
And it's just those
two parameters.
Or you could even make it 1,
like alpha and 1 minus alpha.
I think this stuff
is really cool.
The one detail that I'm
really going to into for FIRM
is the cost equation, which
is based on the Bellman backup
equation that we had.
The cost to go, right, the
expected cost from a belief
state [INAUDIBLE] is--
well, you're going to
take the best action.
So you're going to take the
mide of this whole thing.
You're going to say, it's
the cost of executing
a specific action plus the cost
of colliding with something,
an obstacle, times the
probability of colliding,
right?
That's this term.
And then you've got to
say, well, OK, and then
once I reach a state,
what's the cost from there?
And then I could weight
that by the probability
of ending up in that state.
Does this equation
make sense to people?
There are a lot of symbols,
and honestly, I hate notation,
but it works.
You just plug in--
the cost is I'm
going to take the best action.
It's going to be
the cost of using
that action, the cost
of colliding times
the probability of colliding
given that I used that action
and I started where
I started, and then
the cost from where I end up.
And since you end up in a
probability distribution,
we need to consider
all these cases.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you define
like an action from one place
to another, do you
always think of it
as starting from
mean that you sampled
or from anywhere [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 4: So it's from the--
so formally, it was
from the belief state,
which is the mean, yeah, plus
the variance once it stabilized
to that point.
And the way that variance is
generated, I should have said,
is, you're going to have
models of these quadrotors.
And so I spent a good time
in the ACL with John Howell,
in Course 16.
And you just like let
the quadrotor hover.
You measure its position
for a long time.
And you get a distribution
over where it goes.
AUDIENCE: So what does
the letter M stand for?
PROFESSOR 4: What
is the letter M?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: Right.
So you're summing over-- these
are the belief states that you
could end up in, right?
So if everything
were deterministic,
this would just
be ignore the sum.
It's where you end up.
Realistically you could
end up in some other state
we haven't considered.
AUDIENCE: So just
a quick question.
So those, if we're operating
on a Gaussian space,
then you have
Gaussian observations.
So those are sums over the
observation samples that
are generated when [INAUDIBLE].
So that is a finite sum over the
possible infinite observation
states we might have.
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah.
So there's definitely
[INAUDIBLE]
in terms of where
you could end up.
And even the action
space, there's
a set feedback controller
that you're allowed.
I think the observation, if
you modeled it as a Gaussian,
if you made some
nice assumptions,
it can be tractable
as continuous.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I was [INAUDIBLE].
So for the start, so if you
start with Gaussian noise,
then you have a linear model.
Then your prediction's
going to be Gaussian.
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But then you
have Gaussian observations,
which is great because then
your update is Gaussian
but the observation
space is infinite.
So basically not only you
have two sample positions,
but you also have two sample
potential observations
that you might get
as you go along.
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that
you can basically--
and it's great.
But you end up basically
reducing a possibly infinite
branching, which is your
Gaussian to kind of a
like a Monte Carlo Tree search.
You generate a whole bunch
of meaningful samples,
and those are the ones
that you consider.
So is that where the
sum is coming from?
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah, basically.
And a fun fact, the theorem
that I read and trusted
was that if you
just sample randomly
right from your
configuration space,
you have zero probability
of constructing
a graph that without any
assumptions will be connected.
Whereas for PRMs,
you sample enough
and things will turn out nicely,
not the case with the belief
state.
That's why we need to
make these assumptions.
We're killing it.
We know POMDPs.
Now we get to look at some
really fun graphics generated
from real flights using FIRM.
The big takeaway is that
FIRM prefers safer paths.
We've got two images
that look really similar.
We're going to talk
about one and then show
why they're slightly different.
The test flight that we put this
quadrotor under was we said,
we're going to start
at this configuration.
We're going to go
this configuration.
And there's this
big, blue obstacle.
And there are landmarks that you
can take measurements off of.
So those are these red dots.
We want to compare two planners
right, a PRM and a FIRM
planner.
The PRM planner said, right,
I just want to minimize time.
And so it found the
first path is stay
to the left of the obstacle.
But that's actually
a really narrow path
between the obstacle
and the wall.
On the other hand,
the FIRM planner
said, right, I want to minimize
the linear combination of time
and uncertainty.
And so if you ramp
up the term the wait
for uncertainty, at some
point the path sort of
pops over the obstacle.
It's really cool.
It snaps.
And then you get
this safer path.
But that's longer.
And how do we know it's safer?
Because these ellipsoids
that we've drawn
are the 3D versions of what
we saw for PRM elevated
to the belief space version.
It's the uncertainty
that the quadrotor
has over its true state.
Why is the PRM plan--
why does it have
such big ellipsoids?
It's because when it's
behind the obstacle,
it can't make any of
these measurements
because it can't
see the landmarks.
So it's basically
using dead reckoning.
And the transition model,
right, is not deterministic.
So it's uncertainty grows.
And so we can see these
ellipsoids are bigger for PRM
than FIRM.
And then the reason
I have two images
is they are slightly different.
It's that these landmarks
were fictitious landmarks
that we just said, you can--
and we would generate fake
measurements off of them.
And so we could tune the
noise of the landmarks.
Maybe a little bit
of cheating, but it
allowed us to say, would it
increase the noise from some--
the dimension was
number 0.05 to 0.15.
You can see the uncertainty
ellipsoids from PRM
grow when we increased the
noise, whereas for FIRM, they
stay about the same.
And importantly,
these ellipsoids
grow enough that they start
overlapping with the obstacles.
That represents a very high
probability of collision.
Whereas the FIRM,
the way it managed
to keep these ellipsoids
so small is we
kept the cost function the
same, right-- the same weight
on uncertainty, same
weight on the time, right?
But the uncertainty
was so much higher.
And so we decided, well, I can
sacrifice a little bit of time.
I can take the slower path.
I can just hang out
by landmark, really
make sure I know where
I am before continuing.
And so the path-- the
duration of the flight
took a lot longer
for FIRM as time
would increase but
the uncertainty would
stay about constant.
Do people understand
these graphics?
Great.
All right.
We've got a graph
that just represents
a little more formally
that growing uncertainly.
As noise increases, the variance
along a single dimension, z,
y, to x, for PRM, which
is that, and FIRM.
The variance for PRM is
always higher, and it grows.
For FIRM, it's lower,
and stays about constant.
That's the big takeaway.
FIRM minimizes this uncertainty.
And then the final image
from these results that I
want to show is in simulation.
They said, well, let's actually
measure how often it crashes.
We didn't want to do
this in the real world
because we don't want to crash
the quadrotor that many times.
The gist of it is comparing
a reactive planner
and a deterministic
one [INAUDIBLE]..
As noise increases-- noise was
simulated with wind strength--
the number of crashes
increases for PRM, basically.
And for FIRM, it stays
constant and low.
The reason there
are two lines is
there were two planners with
different time horizons.
The important thing is
FIRM is low and constant.
PRM grows.
We've talked now throughout all
probabilistic planning you ever
need to know, right?
No, not quite.
But we have covered
a lot of stuff.
What are the big takeaways?
We've learned that real-world
problems are stochastic, right?
Quadrotors are not
these perfect machines
that we wish they were.
But it's important to
model them as stochastic.
The problem is once you start
modeling them as stochastic,
it becomes a lot
harder to solve.
But if you make
some assumptions,
or even if you don't,
if you're just get smart
and you do the heuristics, you
can resolve this complexity.
And so I hope you remember
these three points,
you remember this graphic
or that graphic, the idea
that if you take
uncertainty into account,
you get fundamentally
different paths [INAUDIBLE]..
And that can be a good thing.
What questions do
you have, anything?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so far people
have [INAUDIBLE] problems.
So how do the same,
you know, [INAUDIBLE]??
So for instance, we suggest
that this is the maximum risk
we want to take.
Is it possible to integrate
each of our constraints
into your optimization
problem and solve it?
Or [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 4: So I imagine one
thing that I would like to test
is if we go back to this really
crude version of our cost
equation, we can imagine
saying that if we
want to come up with a
bound for uncertainty
that we can tolerate,
you could maybe
like setting an intercept
for this to be that bound
and then just ramping this up.
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE]
multiplier [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 4:
Something like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, exactly.
So it only comes into effect.
Possibly what I said
is a terrible idea.
But it's-- especially
in simulation,
you can just try it out
and see if it works.
AUDIENCE: And just
another question,
you said propagated probability
solution on the networks
is hard.
[INAUDIBLE]
So therefore we can assume
an illustrated area, and then
[INAUDIBLE] normal
distribution, they
are contrary to each other.
Therefore you can
[INAUDIBLE] observation
and then updating [INAUDIBLE]
and form a distribution, right?
PROFESSOR 4: Sure.
So I think that might be making
some assumptions that we might
not be willing to make about
the nature of the distributions
that you're trying to propagate.
I need think about
this some more.
But I think intuitively, we can
understand that any time you're
propagating a distribution
versus a single discrete value,
it's definitely not
going to be easier.
And so as your distributions
become more complex.
Perhaps if you're modeling a
real-world stochastic sensor,
you might not be able to perform
these efficient updates using
conjugate priority.
Any other questions?
Otherwise we-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So all these FIRM
examples you're showing,
this is all planning
done offline.
[INAUDIBLE] offline, right?
Have you expanded this at
all to like an online case?
Or does that all
require re-planning?
And how long does it take?
PROFESSOR 4: Right.
So it's not good, I
can tell you that much.
What's nice is FIRM
generates a policy.
So if you construct
your PRM to say
don't just find
the shortest path,
keep sampling
points until you're
confident that
you're always going
to end up near some point.
You can construct
a policy and then
just online look up
what's my belief that
matches most closely.
It took for-- I think we
sampled 600 nodes in like--
what are the dimensions on this?
So 2 to 3 meter by
8 by 3 meter thing--
it took about 15 minutes.
It was really slow.
Now, granted it was
a virtual machine.
But it's not something we
want to re-plan on the fly.
With PRM, typically
a lot faster.
AUDIENCE: Who was a lot
faster in that case?
PROFESSOR 4: So when
we just did PRM,
I think it was one minute
or something, at least
an order of magnitude.
And you could use other
planners as well, like RRTs.
And there are RRT versions of--
there are POMDT
versions of RRTs.
But [INAUDIBLE].
All right, I'm going to
turn it over to Steve so we
can learn about this project.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE: So I'm just going
to say a few good words
about the Grand Challenge.
So again, the final
assignment will
be released tonight for this.
And as Professor
Warrens mentioned,
it's going to be descoped a
bit from what we originally
had in the syllabus due
to time constraints.
But here's a preview of
what you'll be doing.
So for an overview, it will
be a class-wide collaboration.
So what we're going
to do, you guys
are going to stay in your
advanced lecture teams
and each basically
apply what you've
done, the great work
you've done on that,
onto our hardwork robot
that we have. so it's not
a competition where
each team will be
competing against each other.
And so again,
we're descoping it.
The syllabus originally said
it was 20% of your grade.
It's probably going to be more
like 10% or 15% in the end.
So this is the robot
you guys will be using.
It's called an
[INAUDIBLE] robot.
Usually it has sort of
a robotic arm on it.
But we're actually not
going to be using it
for this [INAUDIBLE].
This base made from a
company from Spain, Orbonix.
It's a pretty cool robot.
One cool thing about it is that
it's actually omnidirectional.
So there are wheels
on your wheels here.
And what that means is
that it can drive sideways,
left to right.
It would make parallel
parking your car very easy.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not going to be
driving it probably this fast
because it's
actually super heavy.
And we don't want
anyone to-- yeah,
we forgot to screw
in that [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
It will be screwed in
during the competition.
But it's a pretty fun robot.
So you guys will
be working on this.
And so the actual
challenge itself,
as we've mentioned many
times throughout this class,
will be a modified
orienteering your challenge.
So there's going to be a few
different challenge stations
that you have to drive to.
And at the stations, there'll be
small computational challenges.
And those computational
challenges
will be a subset of the advanced
lecture teams, not all of them.
And the goal is to complete
as many of those as you can
and try to do that as
quickly as possible.
And it's also going to be
held indoors in our lab space,
where we just showed you.
So that way if it
rains, we can still
have the Grand Challenge
at the end of the semester.
So this is sort of how it's set
up as of last night actually.
So basically the
robot will be abe
to drive around in a
small little LEGO maze
that we set up.
And there's going to be
sort of different things
that you have to do with
in different places.
So what are you actually
going to be doing?
What assignment are you
guys going to be doing?
Well, it's actually
a little flexible.
Since each of you
did different things
for your advanced
lectures, each team
is going to have a bit of a
different assignment applied
to this.
I have some proposed
ideas that I'm
going to talk about in
the next slide here.
But the big thing is that
these are just ideas.
You guys have a lot of
flexibility in this.
You'll be probably working
with the [INAUDIBLE]
a lot to have
access to the robot.
We can arrange extra
office hours for you guys
to come use the
hardware to test things.
So we'll be arranging
all of that things
as sort of on an
as-needed basis.
If you want to--
basically it'll sort
of depend on your team.
AUDIENCE: And the people who'll
be helping out are you, us--
STEVE: Yes, me and
Tiago, who gave a lecture
earlier in the semester
and possibly also
a few other people from our lab.
But we'll be the main
contact points for it.
So of course it should
go without saying,
but all the team members
should contribute equally
within your team.
So it'll be maybe less structure
than in advanced lecture.
But just make sure that
everyone's contributing equally
in the assignment.
And it's going to involve using
this thing called the Robot
Operating System, or ROS,
which is basically a software
framework for communicating and
it's used a lot in robotics.
Just a quick show of
hands, how many of you
have used ROS before?
Oh, wow, so a lot of used ROS.
How many have heard of
ROS, if not used it?
OK, so a lot of people.
So that's a good starting point.
So here are the the proposed
tasks for each group.
And of course, all of
these are up for change.
If you guys want to
change it, let me know.
Basically, so some
of the groups,
it's very clear
how it immediately
applied to the Grand Challenge.
So incremental path planning--
well, we have a mobile robot,
so maybe we can actually
print that on the robot
and get it to change or plan
if something gets in the way.
The semantic
globalization group--
obviously very applicable
to the Grand Challenge.
You need to know where you are.
So the robot that we
have now can actually
do normal metric localization.
So it can sort of
know where it is.
But what will be
interesting to see
is compare the semantic
localization to that one.
But how would you do
semantic localization?
Well, we can use a camera.
And we can choose
the visual learning
through deep classification--
the visual classification
through deep learning group.
So I think these
two groups would
have a really nice synergy
and a really cool way
to work together.
So the MCTS group
are very cool, but I
had a little trouble thinking
about exactly how that
would apply.
So maybe you look like
you have an idea maybe.
AUDIENCE: So to
clarify, all these
are separate runs of the robot?
STEVE: So we're
actually probably going
to run all of them--
so the grid is-- this would be
probably one run of the robot.
We're going to decouple these
so that if one or a subset these
don't work super well, the
other groups will still
be able to run.
So we're carefully
planning that out too.
So the MCTS group,
I was thinking maybe
could solve-- that could be
a really nice way to-- one
of those computational
challenges.
Maybe you have to
play against a human.
And if it wins, great.
You can go faster or
you get more points.
So you could implement
on a different game
other than connect four or
possibly and sort of [wrap it
around [? rod ?] that
to call with that.
So each ability group
I think would also
be a great place to do one
of these challenge stations.
So we could give
you guys puzzle,
say maybe it's some sort
of maze-like state space.
And you have to see could we
even the reach the goal here?
And if you get the answer
right, well, you an
move on to the next stage or
get more points or something
like that.
AUDIENCE: But again, these
are just suggestions.
So for example, they
can do the reachability
for doing motion planning.
STEVE: Yeah, so if you guys
have other suggestions on how
to implement your team's stuff
into the Grand Challenge,
definitely send me an
email, preferably today
or as soon as you
think of the things.
And we can change these.
These are just
suggestions for right now.
The last two are sort of
more planning related.
So planning with temporal logic,
which was Monday's lecture,
I thought would be cool
way to sort of control
the robot's high-level action.
So maybe that could
involve modeling
are Grand Challenge with PDDL.
And maybe with linear
temporal logic goals,
models that you get [INAUDIBLE].
Then you could compile that
and call up to turn around it
and execute that plan
on the actual robot,
do [INAUDIBLE] high-level
actions of the robot.
That's a possibility.
And for today's group,
the infinite horizon
probablistics planning, maybe
you could do something actually
similar.
But instead of modeling
the domain as PDDL
model it as an NVP and
solve it with LAO star,
and get sort of a policy on
how to control the robot.
Maybe we can change
it a little bit so
that certain squares can be
more risky than others or so on.
So again, there's flexibility
in all of these here.
So these are just some
of the suggestions.
Does anyone have any
questions before we--
this all I have.
So anyone have any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How are we
working on [INAUDIBLE]??
Are you [INAUDIBLE]?
STEVE: So it's
basically up to you
guys really divide up the
work amongst yourselves.
It's really different
for every team.
So we're--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So each team is
developing [INAUDIBLE]..
STEVE: Right, yeah.
Each team is really in their
own separate package FIRM.
For example, these
two teams, there's
probably going to be a
common interface where
the output of this one goes
to the input of that one.
So for that one, we're
going to give you
sort of the
interface [INAUDIBLE]
message type package for that.
But other than than, like
for dividing up the work,
you guys [INAUDIBLE] that.
PROFESSOR 2: So your
plans will be integration
if you're trying [INAUDIBLE]
pieces the group is doing.
That we think is, thing
that uses soft engineering
skills [INAUDIBLE].
It can be really unpleasant
to do, take a lot of time.
So we don't want you to
have that experience.
So that's why you can...
If not only what
we wanted you to do
is to be able to get your
own capability [INAUDIBLE]..
If you guys choose to
integrate with other teams
because you're really
excited about that
and because it looks
like the people
that you're working
for [INAUDIBLE]..
Then that's purely your choice.
Is that fair enough?
STEVE: Sure.
It's fine.
Any more questions?
OK.
Sounds great.
[APPLAUSE]